KAITLAN AS WE HAVE BEEN SAYING, HERE
WE GO.
TWO YEARS LATER THIS IS ALL
PLAYING OUT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE INSURRECTION
AND NOW THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING AWARDS, AND THAT'S VERY
SPECIAL FOR THEM.
>> YEAH, M.J. IS TOTALLY RIGHT,
TO SEE THE CONTRAST, TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING TO BE HAPPENING,
WHAT'S PLAYING OUT HERE WITH
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GOING TO
BE DOING TODAY IS REMARKABLE.
JOINING US IS ONE OF THE 12
PEOPLE GOING TO GET THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL TODAY.
MICHAEL FANONE, THE AUTHOR OF
HOLD THE LINE, THE INSURRECTION,
AND ONE COP'S BATTLE FOR
AMERICA'S SOUL.
I WONDER WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR YOU
TO BE HERE ON THE TWO-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING WHEN YOU
WERE COMING OVER HERE TODAY?
>> CAN WAS THINKING IT'S REALLY
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
>> REALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
IT HAS TO BE STRANGE TO BE BACK
HERE TWO YEARS LATER.
>> IN A WAY, I'M TIRED OF COMING
BACK HERE.
I'M FRUSTRATED AT THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE THAT
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ORCHESTRATING THE ATTACK ON OUR
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
WE'RE TWO YEARS OUT.
AND WHILE WE HAVE CYCLED A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE ATTACK,
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL WALKING
AROUND A FREE MAN.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
PLAY OUT, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THIS SPLIT SCREEN WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY, BECAUSE YOU WROTE THIS
OP-ED FOR CNN.COM YESTERDAY AND
YOU SAID THAT HE ONCE TOLD YOU
HE COULD NOT CONTROL THE FRINGE
MEMBERS OF HIS PARTY, AND WE'RE
SEEING IT PLAY OUT IN REAL TIME
WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING THE
SPEAKER'S GAVEL TODAY.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE PREDICTED
WHAT IS HAPPENING TODAY, AND I
CERTAINLY AM NOT SURPRISED.
AGAIN, I HAD THAT CONVERSATION
WITH MYSELF AND OFFICER HARRY
DUNN AND GLADYS SICKNICK, THE
MOTHER OF OFFICER SICKNICK, AND
HE TOLD US, I CAN'T CONTROL THE
FRINGE MEMBERS OF MY PARTY.
AND SO HERE WE ARE.
AUBT YEAR AND A HALF OUT FROM
THAT MEETING, AND KEVIN McCARTHY
IS DESPERATELY SEEKING THE
SPEAKER'S GAVEL AND CANNOT
CONTROL THE FRINGE MEMBERS OF
HIS PARTY.
BY DEFINITION, A LEADER SHOULD
HAVE A FIRM GRASP ON ALL THE
MEMBERS OF HIS PARTY.
HE DOESN'T.
HE'S NOT A LEADER.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
THAT INFAMOUS TRIP HE MADE DOWN
TO MAR-A-LAGO IN THE DAYS AFTER
WHAT HAPPENED HERE TWO YEARS
AGO?
>> I MEAN, THAT JUST GOES TO
SHOW YOU THE TYPE OF PERSON THAT
KEVIN McCARTHY IS.
YOU KNOW, KEVIN McCARTHY CARES
ABOUT KEVIN McCARTHY.
AND HIS CONCERNS LIE IN HIS
PROFESSIONAL FUTURE.
HE'S THE TYPE OF PERSON WHO
WOULD IN THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH
OF THIS, YOU KNOW, HISTORIC
EVENT, THE ATTACK ON OUR
CAPITOL, WOULD LAY THE BLAME AT
THE FOOT OF THE PRESIDENT,
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP,
AND THEN WHEN HE SAW IT AS NOT
BEING POLITICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS,
NOT LEADING TO THE SPEAKER'S
GAVEL, HE GOES DOWN TO
MAR-A-LAGO, KISSES DONALD
TRUMP'S ASS, AND HERE WE ARE.
>> IF KEVIN McCARTHY DOESN'T GET
THE VOTES TO BECOME HOUSE
SPEAKER, WHICH HE MAY NOT, WHAT
DO YOU WANT TO SEE AND TO HEAR
FROM THE PERSON WHO IS
EVENTUALLY THE HOUSE SPEAKER?
>> I WANT TO SEE THE NEW
LEADERSHIP DENOUNCE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE.
AND HOLD ITS MEMBERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE RHETORIC THAT THEY USE,
THAT WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN INSPIRE ACTS OF VIOLENCE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> ONE THING THEY HAVE DONE HERE
IN RECENT DAYS I HAVE NOTICED IS
REMOVE THE MAGNETOMETERS OUTSIDE
THE HOUSE CHAMBER THAT HAD BEEN
PUT IN PLACE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND IN THIS
DAY AND AGE WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH A RISE IN CRIME ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND A RISE IN POLITICAL
VIOLENCE ACROSS THE COUNTRY, AND
WE KNOW THAT THE CAPITOL AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE TARGETS
OF THAT VIOLENCE, THAT WE WOULD
BE DOING ANYTHING TO LESSEN THE
SECURITY POSTURE AT THE CAPITOL.
>> MICHAEL FANONE, I KNOW THIS
IS A STRANGE MOMENT FOR YOU TO
BE HERE TWO YEARS LATER, BUT
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> YES, MA'AM.
THANK YOU.
>>> DON, AS YOU WERE NOTING
THERE, YOU KNOW MICHAEL FANONE
VERY WELL.
TO SEE THIS MOMENT PLAYING OUT
TWO YEARS LATER AS THIS IS VERY
MUCH STILL A CONVERSATION UNDER
WAY WHEN IT COMES TO SECURITY
HERE AT THE CAPITOL, SECURITY
NATIONWIDE, WHAT THESE THREATS
LOOK LIKE NAZWIDE AND THIS FIGHT
PLAYING OUT ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> AND SAFETY.
I COULD SAY THE INSURRECTIONISTS
PICKED THE WRONG PEOPLE TO MESS
WITH AND ALSO THE ELECTION
DENIERS AND LAWMAKERS BECAUSE
MICHAEL FANONE IS GOING TO SAY
WHAT MICHAEL FANONE THINKS, AND
HE'S GOING TO SAY HOW HE FEELS
AS WE HAVE BEEN WITNESS TO ON
MANY INTERVIEWS HERE ON CNN.